due però bene a tutti ragazzi benvenuti
a questo video sono paese ci sono solo
con pietro suo avvocato perché volevo
provare a fare una modalità un po
diversa ti spiego come si gioca
innanzitutto poi prima non conta la
prima un tutorial così come dio si fa
così stiamo facendo e leggo stavo
facendo vedere a pietro funzionava il
gioco è partito uno score dei ragazzi
adesso ho capito tutorial pietro è
pronto si parte allora furono modalità
si arriva ad il primo che elimina cinque
volte l'avversario ha vinto se cado da
solo senza che mi elimini to
praticamente tu non guadagni punti ma io
ne perdo uno che è una cosa un po strana
certo che è mai era pare proprio che con
gli sfondi antisommossa non è proprio il
massimo poi non serve a niente sta roba
qua
[Musica]
eccolo eccolo a posto a 15
ok porco demoni mi ricordo mai che
portano le macchine suo livello ayane
ho perso il punto di pr che vi sono
eliminato la somma è stata difficile
questa barba quale questo questo e
questo è fantastico guarda mi spostassi
motorino eccolo prendino arrivo di no
il ragazzino ha praticamente vinto noi
non ci credo ha vinto lui stavo dice
stavo dicendo praticamente ho vinto io
perché mi passa solo investirti mi ha
beccato uno scuola dal dal basso non si
può neanche potesse succedere scusami
punto qualche pugno mitico team
offendere aggiunti aperto agli colore
tranquillo quella anche carino si
inserisce salse si soffre ancora in
quattro episodi ancora capito come si
sale sopra le robe togliti amico mio ci
penso io mi fermo però non mi hai ucciso
per un accordo con vittore presidente
ucciso e no non mi ha fatto pulite no no
no no non lo so però se non lo so si
conta come non è che conta non conta
maledetto è comunque la cosa bella di
tutto questo che io un anno di
dell'ultimo anno almeno di gameplay non
ho ancora trovato il vissuto con
l'azienda anche io ma per me questo
diverse big ma full flat
non è vero ho vinto io ritrovo noi non
so come non so come prego attenzione
devo riuscire a prenderli non riescono a
girare su stappare togliti ao no no
doneremo morti 22
in tutto questo c'è rispo nathan arma
nova che parte non so dove la lezione
più male è vero non mi aiutato fuori
tutto questo però però adesso aspetto
che non è vero ma mi sa che era dire chi
è ora 2 passare da che parte da fare e
va via
si no il tavolo non ha funzionato come
doveva
mamma mi ha spogliato di rischiato e
rischia cioè fammi tali ma c'è una
bottiglia qua ma forse la mazza non ti
vorrei subiamo non ci credo devi
scegliere che botta cinque secondi mi
sveglio natale amiche praticamente
potevo buttarti giù non l'ho fatto per
bilanciare bravissimo ho fatto una roba
incredibile a lecce è no disponendo
chigi o mega suite sexy omega e furto
boc bostridge bacchetta cosa sto
svolgendo
no no no no pensa che sai che sei andato
contro trecate siamo un po 17 14
mi sa che ho vinto io amico qualcosa me
lo dice basta
la vedo veramente difficile ma questo è
tutto uno sfogo negli ultimi anni che
praticamente è in gradi di guidare
guardando della still have e convocarci
crack in una volta l'ho fatto per
trovare poi e poi proviamo allora io non
ho mai battuto il kraken quello a fare
lido di mettere gli occhi di io non l'ho
mai battuto ed ha lo dico però poi
deviato da questo momenti nell'altro
nell'altro el altra cosa da trocchio la
visione stava scherzando ragazzi
interrompiamo la nostra rivalità un
attimo per provare a evocare il crati
che cosa che ci è successo su una volta
lo staff è bene non so quante volte
visto succedere smette di parlare di un
dio se ci sarebbe la mano evocata è
presente la cosa da per gli serve per
fattori
adesso noi abbiamo aperto guarda che
veramente difficile voga del clan che ci
ho provato una volta ci siamo riusciti
te lo giuro ma è stato veramente
difficile e il secret più secret di
tutto il gioco allora adesso è difficile
fai così stai qua sopra
fidati me stai qua sopra ci sei piloti e
agli amici serve dobbiamo fare le cose
entrambi sono una lunga del kraken
style.it offre non hanno trascurato no
sai rifilati non prendere niente barzan
ok cose muore qualcuno è finita adesso
devi fare questa cosa entra entra dentro
entra e non entra
entra entra nella barca attenzione
bravissimo ora la barca la spingi la
spingi devi salire sulla barca mamma mia
l'ho fare io processo al ci arrivò a
rischio di morire capito chi propulsione
questo vengo io sto vedendo no non si è
donna di dio non cade stai fermo che se
qualcuno cade è finita
[Musica]
ritengo la barca ferma poi mi sembra
proprio fermissima è il loro più ferma
di così composto dai dai ciao faccio io
ma la non sbaglia a non fare niente già
a posto
adesso io prendo la chiave la chiave che
sta qua
vado a mettere la chiave nella torre ok
lo vedo teoricamente adesso si apre
l'ultimo passaggio
il penultimo passaggio per jurgen io
avevo le secret exit stiamo facendo un
casino per evocare sto fratello fatto
l'altra volta è stato un caso
ora appendi ti sa qualcosa dall'altra
parte molla appena qualcosa all'altra
parte appendici al mio 3 1 2 12 salta ci
dicono se cadi abbiamo preso
devi solo centrare la barca come compito
altra vittima no non lo è doveroso
ferite ma sta bene ora dobbiamo
affrontare in chrysler
togliti togliti allora togliti è
difficilissimo e tipicissimo non l'ho
mai dal cielo abbiamo fatto io step e
per sé non si come siccome situazion lo
so come va e vieni di allora prendi gli
oggetti e lo picchi però non puoi
picchiare la mamma era difficile non ho
più chiaro non ammette vi faccio io ho
già morto
volevo prendere veramente devo fare
fuori da solo il kraken neanche dal sole
così difficile ti dico solo questo è la
madonna aumenta l'acqua nome non cui far
fuori da solo l'ambiente
i ragazzi sono solo io crossa per
cracchi va bene la bomba non voglio
elevato devo andare a prenderla granata
che stava giugno è troppo rischio ok
beh questo era il crac il ragazzo è
difficilissimo giudiziario con sé le
fere siamo riusciti a paraty neanche
metà vita ma dopo ancora chi da solo
dobbiamo essere in quattro e tutti 4
prestati per farlo fuori
maurice the time of rocket launcher ma
aspetto tutti gli altri dunque mi
rimangono due punti per vincere più gare
in tutto sto casino doveva mamma mia ma
anche all'ultima killer ragazzi dovrei
riuscire a farla ragazzi si perché no
come ti si salva solo la viola no non è
vero
[Musica]
cos'è è oggi ragazzi ho perso la viola
mi sacro persa aia atomico
la viola era infatti le gambe kisri al
comeback i trial io mio non boscati
scherzavo quando vestiva poco dopo per
l'isola li non puoi neanche accedere se
non so come sia possibile gara così
contenta di aver perso
spero che questo video vi sia piaciuto
conseguito ragazzi servizio piaciuto
affatto un commento è un bel mi piace
qua siam partiti non so chi è non so chi
sia sto lord john it iscriviti al canale
e lasciate la campanella per essere
aggiornati sui nuovi video che escono
poi come sempre ci vediamo al prossimo
video
[Musica]